top 3 des infos du jour et voici l'info
numéro 3 les fake les fake nudes les
fakees nudes ce nouveau fléo des réseaux
sociaux qui s'en prend aux jeunes
mineurs qu'est-ce que c'est que les fake
news depuis quelques semaines des photos
dénudées de jeunes filles mineur généré
par une application d'intelligence
artificielle circule sur les réseaux
sociaux notamment en Espagne et bien
entendu c'est que ça arrive en France en
France l'influenceuse situation on a
déjà été victime onembrasse d'ailleurs
Lena regardez je viens de tomber sur un
truc horrible tu sais ce que c'est le
Deep fake
non mais quoi
ouais c'est des gens qui font des
montages il mettent ta tête sur le corps
d'une femme nu c'est horrible évidemment
pas montrer ça mais ils ont pris un
screen du vlog et il y a une le restque
du corps qui ne m'appartient pas il y a
tellement de meufs sur Internet qui qui
vivent ça ah ouais ah ouais vraiment tu
es horrible c'est vraiment
dégueulasse alors Gill il y a déjà 20
plainte en Espagne et ça touche des très
jeunes filles il y en a une de 12 ans
qui sont en plus d'être dshonor c'est
très dur pour elle victime de chantage
c'estàd qu'on on fait on crée ces photos
fausses et on leur dit si vous ne payez
pas on va les diffuser donc c'est
apprendre très au sérieux parce que ça
peut briser des vies oui parce qu' juste
juste aussi pour les enfants il y a des
photos et c'est les craintes aussi qu'il
y a autour de ça qu'on prennent des
photos d'enfants et qui se retrouvent
sur des réseaux pédophiles ou autres et
ce sont ces inquiétudes là qui sont en
train de monter en Espagne donc c'est
vraiment vraiment grave ça Moon toi qui
tu la mieux placée pour parler de ça je
connais très très bien ce qui se passe
et en fait bon B malheureusement il y a
rien à faire à part se dire que ça va
pas aller en s'améliorant parce que
c'est de plus en plus réaliste ça existe
depuis des années sauf que bah c'est de
plus en plus réaliste parce que
l'intelligence artificielle est de plus
en plus évoluée la seule chose qui y a à
dire et qui est importante c'est qu'il
faut que la la honte elle change de camp
et que malheureusement quand quand ça
arrive la plupart du temps les victimes
elles se sentent coupables honteuses
elles ont honte et il faut vraiment que
elles comprennent que elles sont pas
seul que ça arrive à énormément de monde
et que la honte elle doit changer de C
il faut porter plainte exaement
absolument il porter plinte bon ça sert
pas à grand chose malheureusement oui
mais non mais malré tout faut quand même
faut quand même initier le mouvement
plus il y aura de plainte et peut-être
plus les choses changeront top top 2 des
infos du jour il y a cette série à à
rebondissement entre Jacques cardose
notre ami jacquetlix JAC et l'émission
Complément d'enquête qu'il a présenté
pendant 3 ans dans un instant vous allez
voir l'échange sur X feu Twitter entre
Jacques et son successeur Tristan Wex
euh bah déjà je voudrais qu'on revienne
sur ce que tu as dit Jacques hier sur C
news chez Jean-Marc Morandini c'est vrai
que tu y allé hein a commencé par
dénoncer le manque d'impartialité de
l'émission avec des journalistes qui
sont beaucoup plus ancré à gauche voire
à l'extrême gauche regardez bah les les
insoumis donnent beaucoup de dossiers et
alimentent beaucoup d'enquêtes moi ce
que je dénonce vous savez dans dans dans
cette affaire là c'est un manque
d'équilibre c'est un manque d'honnêteté
intellectuelle lorsqu'on à la tête d'une
émission d'investigation on se doit
d'être impartial et on se doit de euh de
de de de mener des enquêtes aussi bien
d'un côté que de l'autre et c'est
notoriété publique de savoir que les
journalistes sont plutôt plutôt
majoritairement à gauche et plutôt et
qu'ils ont plutôt tendance à vouloir
insister du côté des des des
personnalités de droite et
voilà alors Jacques c'est vrai que laée
tu révèles aussi qu'on t'a interdit
d'aller chez Jean-Marc Morandini
interdit de venir chez nous interdit
dans les émissions du groupe Canal Plus
ah oui alors ça je le maintiens et ah
oui dire ici quoiçon rien de ce que je
dis n'est n'est pas vrai d'ailleurs à
chaque fois en fait il conteste Pasin on
me répond pas sur le fond il répondent
il y a eu deux communiqués de France
Télévision ils n'ont absolument pas
remis en cause ce que j'ai dit ils
répondent en disant non non c'est pas
vrai il y a eu d'autres enquêtes et
cetera nanani nana l'excuse de envoyer
spécial il y a eu un envoyé spécial sur
Mélenchon mais bon sur 3 ans là ils
annoncent c'est ça donc c'est ça qui
vous a répondu Tristant il vous a dit
parce que vous avez dit que faire croire
que le complément d'enquête sens sur les
enquêtes sur LFI alors alors que le
prochain complément d'enquête est
consacré à Sofia Chikirou et les comptes
de campagne de Jean-Luc Mélenchon ça
s'appelle avoir un sacré sens du timing
une nouvelle fois merci pour la promo
euh c'est bien Tristan WEC d'avoir
accepté cette d'avoir accéléré cette
diffusion il y a plus qu'à rediffuser 50
fois cette émission pour venir
équilibrer les choix des deux dernières
saison ça fera du 50 50 autre
possibilité faire le portrait de
Mélenchon et pas de ses proches ouais
c'est c'est pas mal et alors j'ai
regardé un peu hein quand tu fais Le Pen
vend dararmanin Castaner à chaque fois
c'est la personnalité qui est dont on
dresse le portrait Duti et Cera c'est
c'est j'ai encore jamais vu qu'on fasse
le conseiller en communication enfin tu
imagine si sur Chapa on avait fait un
portrait sur to sur toi c'est sans doute
bien mais c'est pas exactement la même
chose surtout qu'il existe des liens il
me semble plus mais la personne est
super intéressante je dis pas mais ça
quelque part ça révèle quelque chose de
l'approche mais pourquoi pas directement
sur Jean-Luc Mélenchon P d'enquête fait
fait le travail à 100 % est-ce qu'il
vont révéler aussi les liens qui
existent entre sopia Chikirou et
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui sont quand même
euh plus personnels que professionnels
aussi aussi exactement mais de tout
façon ut bien comprendre c'est que je
veux jouer le rôle d'un d'un lanceur
d'alerte je le débat il m'appartient pas
je vais pas polémiquer toutes les
semaines avec avec Tristan et l'équipe
j'ai déjà dit que en terme de qualité je
reproche absolument rien à cette
émission ce que ce que ce que ce que je
dis c'est attention à lorsqu'on a une
émission d'investigation du service
public on se doit d'être de charger
aussi bien d'un côté que de l'autre et
de de multiplier aussi un petit peu les
les les approches intellectuelles
systématiquement par exemple lorsqu'on
parle de police moi je c'est
systématiquement à charge contre la
police j'aimerais bien voir des choses
un peu différentes je me souviens que
Benoît disait il faut ça il faut
apprendre duuc il faut apprendre à
penser contre soi-même et bien je les
engage à penser contre eux-mêmes
j'aimerais voir plus de d'enquête en
banlieu plus d'enquêtes sur un certain
nombre de volets de la France qui sont à
mon avis pas assez explorés je voudrais
juste dire quelque chose moi làdessus
c'est que la la patronne de France
Télévision Delphin Hernot on suis jamais
qu ch on s'entend très bien avec ave
delphinnot c'est vrai que
elle elle n'influence pas du tout tous
les magazines d'information de France
Télévision elle ne vraiment ils ont une
totale
liberté alors je confirme jeai déjà dit
sur ce plateau on m'a on m'a dit sur des
enfin on a tourné en dérision ce que
j'ai pu dire sur les sur les réseau je
maintiens que et la présidence et la
direction générale et la direction de
l'info jamais j'ai eu de pression sur
faut faire ceci faut faire cela c'est
pas du tout ce que j'ai dit j'ai
expliqué que en interne à complément
compte tenu de certaines ami de certains
penchants politiqu d'une certaine vue de
la société je pense aussi qu'ils se
ressemblent tous sont des journalistes
formidables mais ils vivent tous dans le
même quartier ils ont tous fait les
mêmes études ils viennent tous des mêmes
origines c'est quand on parle de
diversité intellectuelle c'est aussi ça
c'est aussi ça c'est aussi aller
chercher des gens qui n'ont rien à voir
avec le journalisme c'est s'ouvrir
penser contre soi-même et encore une
fois explorer tous les alors tout ce
qu'ils font est bien c'est pas le
problème c'est une question d'approche
générale d'être un peu plus ouvert tu as
parlé d'US aussi qui n'a qu'une seule
cible les patrons bah oui je suis pas le
seul à le dire elle incarne formidable
bien formidablement bien l'investigation
à france télé mais elle a aussi les
défauts de ses qualités je trouve que
systématiquement c'est quand même
toujours contre les patrons contre la
richesse contre le succès il y a plein
d'émissions dans lesquelles j'ai appris
énormément de choses et vraiment c'est
formidable et il faut que cette émission
continue à exister c'est pas ce que je
dis je dis que encore une fois il faut
peut-être qu'il réfléchiss à faire en
sorte que complément ch et envoyé
spécial ne soit peut-être pas toutes les
trois dans le même mode et dans la même
direction bien sûr JAC une question
juste parce que tout à l'heure tu es
passé un petit peu vite dessus et moi je
trouve que c'est très intéressant même
pour les téléspectateurs tu disais qu'en
fait tu avais pas la possibilité de
venir dans les émissions du groupe Canal
et ça se comment comment ça se bah c'est
c'était très simple tu as un contact
avec le service de presse ah bah tiens
il y a C news ou mini qui voudrait
m'inviter coup de fil de alors là pour
le coup coup de fil du service de presse
qui te dit non non non la direction ne
souhaite pas qu'on y aille tu sais bien
qu' a boyoté c'est Boyé nous8 Boyé c'est
boycoté et j'ai envie de dire là pour le
coup sortez sortez les vidéos qui de
France Télé a été invité chez
Morandini ces deux ou trois dernières
années alors ça n'était pas le cas la
première année pour être tout à fait
honnête 2018-29 j'ai été invité ma
première saison de complément quand je
suis revenu des États-Unis 2018 2019 et
à la fin de 2019 on m'a dit non c'est
fini on va plus chez Morandini et plus
chez news et je pense que bientôt ce
sera plus europen non plus et plus au
JDD enfin mais pourquoi France
Télévision ne veut pas parler à tout le
monde ils ont peut-être quand je dis que
c'est 70 ou 80 % à gauche bah ça
s'explique par par par ce choix-là par
le fait de ne pas vouloir aller dans les
médias bolorés mais c'est pas son rôle
au service public son service public bah
oui voilà allez on va passer au top 1
des infos est-ce que vous connaissez le
bour c'est un nouveau sport qui fait
beaucoup beaucoup parler agit de combat
médiéval en armure les mecs ont des
haches des épées dans le jardin des que
cou du son sur l'ER de la plaine et
c'est plutôt dangereux le weekend
dernier c'était la Coupe de France et un
des finalistes a été gravement blessé à
coup de ha Édouard m président de la
Fédération Française de Bour est avec
nous dans un instant mais regardz
d'abord à quoi ça
ressemble
[Musique]
bon merci dard d'être là vous êtes
président de la Fédération Française de
Bour c'est sûrement c'est c'est vous
faites beaucoup de télé non non c'est é
sont aussi F voilà qu'est-ce que le bour
alors le bour c'est un sport qui nous
vient directement du du Moyen-Âge donc
c'est une pratique très ancienne qui se
pratiquait donc par les chevaliers vous
l'avez bien compris qui pratiquait du
combat en armure sans but de se tuer
donc dans un but praticalement sport
surtout sportif et aujourd'hui au 21e
siècle on a un peu remis au boutt du
jour cette pratique en adaptant les
règles et en pratiquant ça donc
sportivement vous voyez dans dans ces
tournois oui oui bonjour monsieur oh
calme calme calme calme calme je te le
dis calme calme calme avec avec vous
êtes un danger public le Bou c'est pas
une reconstitution historique c'est un
combat quelqu'un a été gèvement blessé
alors que normalement vos armes doivent
être factis si je puis dire ou protégé
là quelqu'un a reçu un coup de hache
donc moi je suis pour l'interdiction de
ce qui se veut dans votre esprit un
sport mais qui pour moi est une
mascarade extrêmement dangereuse
qu'avez-vous à répondre à ça cher
Monsieur ben c'est un sport de combat
comme vous l'avez dit effectivement au
même titre que la boxe que le MMA que le
karaté donc effectivement il y a des
coups qui sont portés la particularité
de notre sport comme je l'ai dit c'est
que comme les chevaliers avant nous on
pratique en armure avec des armes
médiévales qui sont non létales
c'estàdire qu'elles sont contrôlées par
des arbitres elles obéissent à un cahier
des chargge très précis elles sont donc
ni pointu ni tranchante
2500 € l'armure hein je précise 2500 €
l'ARM si le me si le mec il a envie de
la payer que tu fais chier mais c'est
non seulement dangere mais non mais
qu'est-ce que tu nous emmerdes vous
passez du cocalan sur la dangerosité le
un point de vue idéologique parce que
d'abord ça coûte cher alors le golf ça
coûte cher il y a plein de sport la
deuxième chose qui qui te gêne aussi
c'est le côté aussi chevalier décoromme
l'histoire de France une sorte de
détestation pour c'est un massacre en
côe de ma vous
massacre à coup de comm au MO il Antoine
DUP hier il s fait fracturer la mâchoire
ça tuas pas te posé de problème voilà et
c'est du rugby c'est très violent il y a
des commion il se tap dessus vous
trouvez ça bien vous êtes sur PL encadr
tu Doig t'envoyer là-bas je suis de Doig
de t'envoyer là-bas alors vous devriez
essayer du bien vous massacreer un coup
de
ha c'est pas ça ce sport
justement c'est le même Gilles qui
encensé les combats de MMA il y a
quelques o les gens sont par terre tu
t'éclates la gueule à coupas du sang
partout là tu t'en fous là c'est un
sport qui est traditionnel qui remonte à
nos ancêtres qui célèbr la
mais voilà c'est en fait c'est de
l'ordre du spectacle
mais ça veut juste dire fracas déjà rien
que le nom du sport ça veut dire fracas
et moi j'ai j'ai écouté des
personnesis toi tu fais des
safaris oui moi je veux pas avec les
animaux non mais j'ai écouté des mecs
qui font ça des personnes qui font ce
sport est-ce que c'est vraiment un sport
moi j'ai pas l'impression que ce soit un
sport et ils disent quel plaisir de
pouvoir se défoncer la tête sans règles
sans moi j'ai j'ai vu sur YouTube des G
qui témoignent kiff c'est faire la
guerre comme des animaux moi pour moi
c'est pas un sport c'est une
représentation à la limite qu'one au pu
du fou pour en plaisantant sans vraiment
se faire du mal là là on se fait
vraiment du mal moi pour moi c'est pas
du sport le sport c'est pas ça des
valeurs il a pas de
valeuré prière chose Monsieur ver c'est
codif c'est un sport avec des règles
consulter site combal.com F alors les
règles sont très long a
plusieurs très précises pour éviter un
maximum les accid il y a notamment
interdiction de frapper à la nuque de
frapper les gens qui sont au sol
contrairement au MMA de frapper dans les
pieds de frapper à l'entrejambe voilà il
y a toute une série de coups qui sont
interdit les coups des stock qui pourrai
planter qui pourrait crever un il par
exemple sont totalement interdit pour
revenir ce que vous disiez non B ne veut
pas dire fracas si vous avez lu le
mémoire de recherche qui est présenté
sur notre site Internet et ben vous
lirez et oui ben des fois les médias
font des erreurs ce sera pas
Laour ça vient du mot heur our h RD
voilà le mot he qui est rendu transitif
par le préfixe B voilà qui c'est pas
beaucoup mieux et puis à l'heure où M
est en guerre le monde est en guerre il
y a des gens
qui j'assume ce que je dis jou à la GU
guerre comme dans l'ancien temps moi
personnellement ça m'amuse
pas je suis ravi d'avoir votre avis
personnel à ce
je la suppression du paintb ouais du
rugby c'est la Coupe du monde de rugby
en ce moment je crois qu'
se pourant alors à ce momentl où est la
différenceine vous vouliez quoi non je
voulais qu'il précise effectivement s'il
y avait des règles mais il l'a dit qu'
il y a plein de pages de règles donc t
mie exactement voilà je vous en ai donné
quelquesunes là pas que des hommes
d'ailleurs qui font cette discipline
aussi des femmes exctement voilà il y a
des femmes aussi bien sûr moins
nombreuses que les hommes mais en
développement on a un comité d'ailleurs
qui est dédié à la pratique du bour
féminin les femmes combattent selon les
mêmes règles que les hommes dans une
catégorie séparée comme dans tous les
autres sports et elles apprécient tout
autant que les hommes très bien ça oui
oui just comment puisque du coup vous
dites que c'est pas pointu que c'est pas
tranchant comment vous expliquez que du
coup il y a un homme qui se retrouve en
urgence absolue alors ce qui s'est passé
c'est que les armes sont quand même en
acier c'est quand même des réplique
d'armes médiévales les mettre en
plastique comme ça au moins c'est tout
alors ce serait possible mais si vous
voulez à ce momentl ça changerait
complètement le sport et ça rendrait un
petit peu obsolète et inopérante les
armures le principe c'est que on utilise
des armes qui sont en acier mais comme
les chevaliers dans l'ancien temps on a
aussi des armures qui sont intégralement
en acier en titane avec du rembourrage
en dessous et cetera donc on est quand
même très bien protégé il avait jamais
eu d'accident comme ça en 15 ans que moi
je pratique cette malheure il pas mal ce
qui pass ce qui s'est passé c'est que il
a simplement eu pas du tout de chance
c'est-àdire qu'il a une protection on a
ici une jupe d'écaille en fait qui fait
tout le tour de la taille laen était
ouverte sur le devant et au niveau de
l'entrejambe on a la coquille comme dans
les autres tours de combat qui vous
protège les parties quoi et le coup est
arrivé pile entre l'ouverture de cette
jupe d'écaille et la coquille ah merde
voilà ce qui arrive ça n'était jamais
arrivé avant là c'est
arrivéci tous les sportaccidents de
cartes de cheval
de exactement oui oui je vis juste
revenir à la base quand on voit ces
images là moi je découvre un peu ce
sport depuis quand il y a eu un tel
engouement autour de ce sport pourquoi
quel est l'intérêt en tout cas des
adhérents d'aller se battre en
costume C l'engouement du du Fou les
spectacles historionstition Histor on
est beaucoup on est beaucoup alors
certains personnellement ça ne les
intéresse pas je vous entends très bien
monsieur pe-re ça vous plaît pas ça il y
a aucun souci mais on est beaucoup en
fait à avoir été bercé dans notre
enfance par des conttes et des légendes
à avoir vu des des séries qui se passent
Moyen-Âge des films avoir lu des livres
REM voilà Game of Thrones on a visité
des des musées ou des
écoparc on s'intéresse à ça ce qui fait
que il y a ce rêve un petit peu de vivre
le rêve du chev combien d'adér vous avez
on a on a presque atteint les les 500
adhérents dans not fédération cette
année ouais donc il y a 500 adhérents et
on a fait de ça l'info du
jour bravo
l'équipe bravo s'arrêter là merci merci
d'être venu merci d'êt venu merci
beauoup merci merciêtre venu beaucoup
prenez-moi jour ou avec plaisir pour
s'échanger de C de calme-toidard
ARD prenez-le ça va le calmer merci en
tout cas merci d'avoir été avec nous on
se retrouve dans un instant les Chéries
bien sûr et on aura l'histoire du jour
les fourmis de feu arrivent en France
faut-il en avoir peur les fourmis de feu
je peux vous dire en avoir dans son slip
à tout de suite